العاصمه الاندونيسيه جاكرتا الواقعه في
جزيره جاوه ضاقت على سكانها الذين يبلغ
عددهم نحو 11 مليون نسمه وصارت عنوانا
للاكتضاض والتلوث البيئي وازمه دينيه
وعرضه ايضا لتكرار الفيضانات اضافه الى
قربها من بؤر الزلازل والبراكين ولهذا تسع
سلطات البلاد الى نقل العاصمه الى كلماتان
شرقيه جزيره بورلي
تدريسيا انخفضت اليابسه في جاكرتا خلال 15
عاما مضت بما يصل في بعض السواحل الى نصف
متر دون سطح البحر ويتوقع ان تستمر هذه
ظاهره المرتبطه باستهلاك المياه الجوفيه
وتغيرات المناخ لكن باحثين يرون ان نقل
عاصمه لا يعني التخلي عن اصلاحهالي جاكرتا
نور
المشكلات البيئيه في جاكرتا وتتجه للبحث
عن بيئه افضل هذا ليس حلا فهي ستحتاج الى
انفاق موازنتين الاولى لاصلاح جاكارتا
والثانيه لبني عاصمه جديده
[موسيقى]
يبعد عن جاكرتا بنحو الفين كيلومتر رحله
تستغرق نحو ساعتين جوا وصلنا مدينه مالك
بابابان ومنها توجهنا برا الى موقع
العاصمه الجديده التي ستسمى تاره الحكومه
تعد بحمايه هذه المساحات الخضراء التي
ستشكل ثلثي المساحه الكليه لمدينه نيسان
تاره وستكون حاضره تجمع بين تقنيات
المستقبل وحمايه البيئه
نانسي عجرم
منذ القدم ولم تتحقق والان بدانا تنفيذها
وهناك اساس قانونيا لانشاء عاصمه للبلاد
من ابرز التحديات التي ستواجه عماره
العاصمه الجديدهرا هو مدى التزام الحكومات
المستقبليه بمتابعه المشروعي واستكماله
وتقدم تكلفته الاوليه باربعه وثلاثون
مليار دولار اما السكان الاصليون هنا في
يرحبون بتشييد عاصمه قرب قراهم ويامرون ان
تكون فرصه لتغيير حياتهم وتحسين مستقبل
ابنائهم واحفادهم
العاصمه الجديده لصالح مجتمعنا فنحن لا
نريد الله على حالنا ونرجوا ان نشهد تقدما
والحمد لله الذي جعل الحكومه تتجه الى
اعمار هذه المنطقه موقع العاصمه الجديده
يتوسط ارخبيل اندونيسيا وهو قريب من خليج
مالك بنبان
لعهد جديد ذاك ما تطمح اليه الحكومه
الاندونيسيه ضمن مساعيها لتخفيف مركزيه
جاكرتا وجزيره جاوه وتحقيق التنميه شماليه
وشرقيه البلاد لكن دون ذلك عقبات كثيره
فالمشروع على ضخامته يظل مرهمونا بتغيرات
المزاج السياسي وتقلبات الاحوال
الاقتصاديه خلال عقدين المقبلين صاحب
الجاسم الجزيره اقليم كلمنت الشرقيه شرقيه
جزيره بورنيو